and welcome back to Hannity so the fake
news destroy Trump liberal media losing
their mind yet again over something
President Trump said at the White House
during an event honoring Native American
code talkers who served in World War two
president Trump poked fun at one of his
favorite targets Democratic senator
Elizabeth Warren who has been proven to
have lied about her native american
heritage here's what he said you were
here long before any of us were here
although we have a representative in
congress who they say was here a long
time ago
they call her Pocahontas but you know
what I like you because you are special
now of course the liberal media is
jumping all over the use of the word in
the name Pocahontas which is called
Warren repeatedly but shouldn't they be
more focused on going after Warren who's
exploited her fake Native American
heritage for her own personal gain here
with reaction
former deputy assistant to the president
Fox News national security strategist
Sebastian Gorka dr. Gorka Warren is now
saying Trump called me a racial slur
will not shut me up well there was a big
investigation and the use of minority
status when it's not accurate seems to
be a far bigger offense that the lip
left we'll never talk about your
reaction it's a continuation of
everything you've covered so far in your
show there is a protected class in this
country and it's the elite of the left
there like Untouchables if you're Canas
if you're Al Franken if you're Bill
Clinton you can preach that you're for
women you can preach that you're for the
victim but when you get caught
red-handed
nothing happens to you it's the same
with Senator Warren this is a woman who
had a no-show job or a job where she
taught one course and then picked up
four hundred thousand dollars from from
Harvard a year and then she's culture
let's use the correct phrase short she's
using cultural appropriation she's using
the Native American heritage to get that
job and then when the conductive worker
know the left the left couldn't prove it
they tried their best to prove it the
best we found out is that she said well
when she was young her family told her
that she had Cherokee blood in her no
proof zero proof when the president
points it out then she's the one who's
been abused wrong you abused the
American native heritage when you lied
about your ethnic background side take
advantage of my not getting get my NER
minority status right she never deserved
right and which Harvard Harvard then
waived as a flag in 1996 when they were
accused of being too white they said no
no no no no look we've got this woman on
our faculty and she's part Cherokee
bogus it's this is this is fake news
it's classic fake news Sean all right
what do you think we've got all this
hypocrisy going on as it relates to
sexual harassment the very same
Democrats that many of whom were
involved in smearing all the Clinton way
I mean smearing and defending what we
now know is predatory behavior of Bill
Clinton and the outrage they show only
when Republicans are accused of of such
things now they talk about due process
now they talk about not rushing to
judgment I'm consistent I think that
should be the case it take everything
seriously there are two serious charges
serious but people do still deserve the
presumption of innocence and that's even
John Conyers but they politicize this
your thoughts look that's the American
Way we have to be a nation of law and
order of rule of law even for the elites
as my good friend trial by media not
trial by media and not it not false
accusations that have just built upon
and built upon look Sean it's very
simple as my good friend Chris Plant who
has the morning radio show here in DC
says all the time if the left didn't
have double standards they wouldn't have
any standards at all that's the bottom
line it's flexible it's made of rubber
and if you're one of us if you're
Hillary if you're bill if you're Conners
if you're Franken don't worry when you
get caught we'll cover for you what
should happen in those cases in the
Franken case you have evidence and you
have an admission oh well not on
everything in Conyers case he says no in
Moore's case he says didn't happen well
ideally the elite should police itself
they should say no you have to leave you
must be you must show that you have
moral fiber and you must resign or you
must be sacked from your positions if
there's a legal case to be made if
there's actual sexual assault that
should be investigated to the end of the
trail agree there whether they're
Americans or whether they're Democrats
agreed I don't think it's hard to find
all right as the Senate in this tax bill
we have 30 seconds yeah pass and and do
you have any faith it will pass I give
it a 50-50 shot if they don't realize if
the if the GOP establishment doesn't
realize that their necks are on the line
if this doesn't pass then then more fool
them more fool them all right Sebastian
corker always good to see it thank you
for being with us